c'est l'heure de la traite au Gaec
servant de vos la douzaine de vaches
laitières rentre à la ferme en
empruntant ce petit chemin il a été
réalisé avec des structures alvéolaires
remplies d'agrégats c'est l'une des
innovations de l'entreprise beauceron
Eco végétale la dalle ecorster permet
une stabilisation des sols c'est en
polyéthylène basée 100% recyclé 100%
recyclable c'est neutre pour
l'environnement parce que c'est stable
aux Uv ça ne se dégrade pas il y a
aucune pollution du sol
la structure est faite pour durer 20 ans
le polyéthylène provient de sacs de
supermarché recyclés les chemins
filtracis la pluie et les déjections des
bovins facilitant le travail de
l'éleveuse
on
va aller faire par jour
c'est forcément si elle marche dans la
gadoue elles arrivent les pâtes toute
sale et donc elle nous salissent et ça
il se fait pour traire c'est quand même
moins c'est fini et après c'est vrai
qu'en élevage laitier les problèmes de
pâtes sont quand même assez importants
c'était facile d'installation aussi ce
qui est très confortable quoi
[Applaudissements]
voici le principal site de production
déco végétal ici ce sont des dalles pour
végétaliser des parkings ou des toits
qui sont préparés c'est ainsi que
l'entreprise a commencé en créant un
produit servant à filtrer les eaux de
ruissellement bien avant que l'on
commence à parler de bouleversement
climatique et on a fait la première
dalle en gazonnée en Europe en 1994 nous
pensions à infiltrer les eaux pluviales
de manière à réalimenter les nappes
phréatiques à la source mais on parlait
pas d'Ilo de chaleur on parlait pas de
réchauffement climatique la recherche
expérimentale a ensuite permis de
découvrir toutes les vertus du produit
elles sont démontrées ici au siège
Aurélien de l'entreprise tous les toits
sont végétalisés les parkings sont en
structure perméables des équipements
désormais réclamés par toutes les villes
de France afin de réduire l'impact du
réchauffement climatique résultat la
petite PME compte désormais plus de 120
salariés et près de 20 millions d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires annuel
en matière de parking perméable on est
leader pour les toitures végétalisées on
fait partie des acteurs principaux et on
va se développer de manière à
accompagner nos clients en dehors des
frontières on est en Belgique
aujourd'hui et on va continuer le site
de Broué d'ailleurs appelé à croître
rapidement l'évolution de la législation
sur la préservation de la ressource en
eau lui assure un avenir florissant